we're told that Burger barn makes
dipping sauce by mixing two spoonfuls of
honey with 1/2 spoonful of mustard
sandwich town makes dipping sauce by
mixing four spoonfuls of honey with one
spoonful of mustard which dipping sauce
has a stronger mustard flavor so pause
this video and see if you can work
through that on your own all right now
let's think about the ratios of honey to
mustard at each of these restaurants so
first let's think about the scenario
with burger barn
so I'll just say B B for short for
burger barn so they have two spoonfuls
of honey for every 1/2 spoonful of
mustard so the ratio of honey to mustard
in terms of spoonfuls is two spoonfuls
of honey for every 1/2 spoonful of
mustard so this is the ratio of honey to
mustard let me write this this is honey
and this right over here is mustard now
let's look at sandwich town so I'll call
that s T so sandwich town makes dipping
sauce by having four spoonfuls of honey
for every one spoonful of mustard so the
ratio of honey to mustard is four
spoonfuls - one spoonful so once again
that is honey and that is mustard now
can we make these equivalent ratios or
can we compare them somehow well let's
see we have one half spoonful of mustard
here we have one spoon of mustard here
so what if we multiplied both the
mustard and the honey spoonfuls by two
that still would be an equivalent ratio
because we're multiplying by the same
amount so if we multiply by two in both
situations you have four spoonfuls of
honey for every one spoonful of mustard
well that's the exact same ratio that we
have at sandwich town so it actually
turns out that they have the same
concentration of mustard they have the
same ratio of honey to mustard four
spoonfuls of honey for
every spoonful of mustard in either
situation let's do another example so
here we are asked or we are told we are
told Patrick's favorite shade of purple
paint is made with four ounces of blue
paint so I'm interline that in blue four
ounces of blue paint for every three
ounces of red paint for every three
ounces of red paint so the ratio of blue
paint to red paint is 4 ounces of blue
four ounces of blue for every 3 ounces
of red so for 2/3 which of the following
paint mixtures will create the same
shade of purple alright pause this video
and see if you can figure it out on your
own so this is 3 ounces of blue paint
mixed with 4 ounces of red paint well
this is a ratio here of 3 to 4 and even
though it's dealing with the same
numbers this is a different ratio the
order matters this is four ounces of
blue for every 3 ounces of red this is
saying three ounces of blue for every 4
ounces of red so we can rule this one
out eight ounces of blue paint mixed
with six ounces of red paint so here
this ratio is 8 ounces of blue for every
six ounces of red well are these
equivalent ratios well the difference or
you can go if you multiply by two in
either case you will get 2 8 2 6 4 times
2 is 8 3 times 2 is 6 so this is indeed
an equivalent ratio so we would select
this one alright here they say 6 ounces
of blue paint mixed with 8 ounces of red
paint so this is once they've swapped
the blues and the red relative to this
one so this is a ratio of 6 to 8 so let
me write this down so this is a ratio 6
ounces of blue paint for every 8 ounces
of red paint so just like we ruled out
that first one this is dealing with the
same numbers but in the different order
and the order matters will rule that out
20 ounces of blue paint
20 ounces of blue paint for every 15
ounces of red paint so are these
equivalent well let's think about it to
go from 4 to 20 you could multiply by 5
and to go from 3 to 15 you could
multiply by 5 so we could multiply by
the same factor to go from 4 to 3 to 20
to 15 so this is indeed an equivalent
ratio 12 ounces of blue paint mixed with
16 ounces of red paint alright so this
is a ratio here of 12 ounces of blue for
every 16 ounces of red so let's think
about this to go from 4 to 12 you would
multiply by 3 now if you multiplied 3 by
3 you would have a 9 here not a 16 so
this is definitely not an equivalent
ratio another way of thinking about it
you have in terms of ounces you have
more ounces of blue than you have of red
for any of the equivalent ratios but
here you have more ounces of red than
blue so once again another way of
realizing that that is not equivalent
so only B and D are the equivalent
mixtures that will provide the shade
same shade of purple to have that same
shade you need the same ratio of blue to
red